-Another weekend,
another racist outburst
from our racist president.
For more on this, it's time for
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It seems impossible now, but
there was a time not so long ago
when you'd go a whole weekend
without hearing a word
from the president.
That was when we had a president
who actually did stuff.
Obama wasn't tweeting all day
because he was busy reading,
holding meetings, or,
at the very least, working out.
I mean, look at that.
On top of being president,
he was recording
instructional fitness videos.
That one was called
"Obama-nate Your Abs."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, remember?
You could just do normal stuff
without your phone
buzzing constantly
because the president said
something racist and insane.
It used to be, when you were
in the grocery store,
and you heard someone say
"son of a bitch,"
it was because they were
out of paper towels.
Now, it's because they
looked down at their phone,
and saw the president
scream-tweet something
in all caps, like,
"The bust of Abraham Lincoln
is spying on me.
Not nice!"
[ Laughter ]
Trump's malignant narcissism
won't let him go 5 seconds
without being
the center of attention.
All day, every day, there's
Trump, on every TV you pass by,
sweating, red-faced,
fighting with reporters,
doing that thing
where he points at his head
to show everyone
he knows where his brain is.
[ As Trump ] "The doctors say
it looks like a pumpkin
that got left on the stoop
for too long."
[ Normal voice ]
This is...
This is our life, now.
Long, long after he leaves
office, his dumb face
will be burned into
our flat screens
even when
they're turned off.
[ Laughter ]
And on top of that, Trump spends
all day searching for ways
to blame or attack enemies
for literally anything,
no matter what it is.
For example, on Friday,
he was asked
if he was planning an extended
stay at his Bedminster resort
in New Jersey,
and in his response,
he found a way to take
a truly insane swipe at Obama
over the air-conditioning
in the White House.
-So, I go to Bedminster,
which is a beautiful place,
but it's never a vacation.
It's working.
-Are you planning a trip
to Bedminster
over an extended
period of time?
-I hope not,
because I like working.
I'd rather be right here,
you know?
But probably over a short
period of time.
A lot of times,
you go,
and they do a lot of work
in the White House.
For instance, the Obama
administration worked out
a brand-new air-conditioning
system for the West Wing.
And it was so good
before they did the system.
Now that they did the system,
it's freezing or hot in here.
-Well, maybe it's hot
because you're president,
and this is Hell.
And maybe it's freezing because,
when you were elected,
Hell froze over.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump has been...
losing his mind,
in part over the various
Congressional investigations
into his corruption,
because he's a fundamentally
lawless president.
And one of the Democrats charged
with investigating Trump
in Congress is Maryland
Congressman Elijah Cummings.
He's the chair of
the House Oversight Committee,
so it's literally his job
to conduct oversight
of the administration.
For example, Cummings has
criticized and held hearings
on the cruel
and inhumane conditions
in border
detention centers,
which even Trump's own
Department of Homeland Security
called "dangerous" in a report
released earlier this month.
And Cummings has also
been investigating
the use of private accounts
to conduct official business
by some of Trumps' closest
aides and advisers.
Cummings is doing his job
by investigating Trump,
and trying to hold this
administration accountable.
So, naturally, Trump responded
the only way he's capable of --
with a vile,
racist tirade.
-President Trump picked
another Twitter fight
with an African American
lawmaker,
calling representative
Elijah Cummings
a "brutal bully" for
"shouting and screaming"
at Trump officials
testifying before Congress.
"The border is clean,
efficient, and well-run,
just very crowded,"
Mr. Trump tweeted
before disparaging Cummings'
West Baltimore district
as a "disgusting,
rat and rodent infested mess."
-So, once again, he attacked
a Congressmember of color
by using the word "infested,"
just as he did two weeks ago
when he told four Democratic
Congresswoman of color --
three of whom were born here,
and all of whom are Americans --
to go back to the
"crime-infested" places
from which they came.
Hey, man, the only thing that's
infested, here, is your brain.
You know, that one.
Yeah.
I mean, I'd ask...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'd ask you to apologize
to these lawmakers
for your racist tirades,
but you can't even
say the word "lawmakers."
-He has worked in
both houses of Congress,
advising lawmarkers.
-That's right.
[ Laughter ]
Lawmarkers --
as in, "I think Trump
has been sniffing
lawmarkers."
[ Laughter ]
He keeps coming back to
this racist trope
because he's a racist.
It's the core of
his ideology.
On Fox News Sunday,
Trump's acting chief of staff,
Mick Mulvaney,
tried to defend the tweets,
absurdly claiming they had
nothing to do with race.
But host Chris Wallace
wasn't having it.
-These is a clear pattern,
here, Mick.
The fact is that,
before his inauguration,
the president tweeted
about John Lewis,
a Black Congressman --
this is before
his inauguration --
he should spend time in
his crime-infested district.
Then, two weeks ago,
he goes after
the four members of
"The Squad" --
all women of color --
and says they should go back
to the "crime-infested countries
from which they come."
Then, he talks about
Elijah Cummings,
and he says his district is
"rat and rodent infested."
"Infested."
It sounds like "vermin."
It sounds subhuman.
And these are all six --
members of Congress
who are people of color.
-I think you're spending
way too much time
reading between the lines.
-I'm not reading
between the lines.
I'm reading the lines.
-Yeah.
He's just reading the lines.
It's obvious.
It's not like you need to
play clips of him backwards,
like a Beatles record, to hear
some sort of secret message
admitting he's a racist.
Although, I wonder,
if we tried it...
-I'm a racist.
[ Laughter ]
-The only remedy for a corrupt,
racist president is impeachment.
Congress needs to use
their Constitutional power
to tell a coherent story
about this president's racism,
his corruption,
and his self-dealings.
Congress needs to
do their job as...
-Lawmarkers.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]